[Music]
[Applause]
yeah Seton when you were in high school
how the idea of you becoming an NFL
player
was it something that was on your mind
or like on your coach's mind in high
school or was that sort of far off
not at all so probably was my dream
until like sixth grade maybe
um my dad's five nine 170 pounds and I
was like a fury Real Late Bloomer so I
wanted to be a broadcaster I wanted to
like work for ESPN or be a writer for
Sports Illustrated and then I all of a
sudden even in 10th Grade I was six foot
175.
but then my junior year I sprouted and
was almost six four two ten and started
getting a couple scholarship offers and
interest from Ivy League schools but I
remember specifically Seton thinking
I'm never gonna be an NFL player like
I'm not even good enough for major
college Penn State or Notre Dame or
whatever so if I can go to Princeton or
Harvard because of football I have to do
it so not even um not even a spec on the
radar screen wow I would say in high
school just thrilled that it enabled me
to go to an Ivy League school which is
really good timing because that's
actually the story I have
for our next guest who joins us every
Wednesday at this time but before I
bring on Marcellus Wiley who does a
great job
posting his podcast on the damn pot uh
Dan Patrick Podcast Network I thought he
had some interesting things to say about
Russell Wilson recently on the show
the declaring issue was Russell Wilson
wanted the plays to break down so he can
show up and show out and that's
something that is not replicable that's
not something that you can repeat as a
coordinator that's not a play you can
call hey hey we're gonna run 42x
breakdown play on three like
stay on script stick to the script and
Russell Wilson is actually Better Off
Script
and imagine if you're the coordinator of
the coach what player are you calling
Off Script so his inaccuracy is showing
his ugly head but more importantly that
broken inner clock that he always had he
couldn't Feel the Rush or he wanted to
rush to come so he can activate Russell
Wilson dipping it in and go out there
and just run around in circles and seven
seconds later complete a pass
that is from more to it on The Dan
Patrick Podcast network from Marcellus
Marcellus does a really good
like that I like that that was the
highlight there Marcellus really
appreciate you coming on the show now I
can't remember if I told you this story
or not before but the guys are gonna
love this okay so Seton just asked me
about you know me in the NFL or whatever
and I said I was a late bloomer the
first letters I got were winner of my
junior high school from Ivy League
schools so spring break okay I didn't
tell any of my buddies what I was doing
for spring break but because I was gonna
go visit Harvard Yale and Columbia and I
don't want to tell them that because
they would have been like yeah right
dude you're not smart enough to go there
who do you think you are whatever I just
didn't want to say anything so I go up
to Harvard see the campus whatever but
there was no I didn't see any players go
to Yale see the campus meet the coaches
still haven't met any players the first
school
where I actually saw what ivy league
players looked like because I had no
idea Mike Donnelly okay the great Mike
Donnelly they're great yes takes me into
the weight room
at Columbia and I'm a junior in high
school this is spring break this would
have been spring of 96. I'm like six
four two thirty I'm wearing my why I'm
missing letter jacket because in
Pennsylvania that's what you do if you
want girls you put the leather jacket on
and two players come up to me to say hi
Marcellus Wiley who was a six five 275
pound DN and Rory Wilfork yes I remember
thinking two things one is these guys
are really nice that's really cool they
came over to talk to me and secondly I
can't even play in the ivy league
Marcellus was like six five 275. you had
all kinds I was like oh my God and
because Colombia was historically really
bad now I know you guys that year you
had been like eight and two or that next
year you were whatever but I was like
this is what the Columbia dudes look
like yeah you were like dude this NFL
dream I have is never going to happen
because you're like if these two dudes
are in the ivy league what the hell does
another Dame player really look like in
live in person but you actually I was
just so upset that in my mind I couldn't
even play in the ivy league I was so I
was like oh my gosh I can't play against
guys like this but people don't know
your story real quick before we get any
other things
refresh my memory didn't you go to
Columbia as like a six to 200 pound
running back or something oh even
smaller than that I was a six foot 180
pound kick returner slash running back
like I was damn near a tall work done it
was it was crazy and then I just kept
putting on weight 20 pounds and I would
grow one inch every single year
um all my friends knew it was coming I
was a late bloomer like you probably
even later but uh my mother was huge and
I say that respectfully she was six one
two fifty she was like Mike Singletary
and here I am in college playing
football and I'm smaller than my mom so
everyone knew it was coming it just
happened on Columbia's watch so there's
two funny things about that Marcellus
number one
um my wife and I talk about this all the
time because she was with me during my
seven years in the NFL
some guys have big dads some guys don't
every guy has a big mom every guy has a
big mom right do you know any NFL
lineman whose mother is not
um a a bigger woman oh yeah oh yeah of
course I mean that's how Thanksgiving
dinner gets cooked and then that's how
those players grow because mama had the
the triceps hanging and Big Mama was in
the kitchen so yeah my mom was gigantic
and I used to always just sit there like
guys would tease me but like your mom is
huge and you know it's just jokes but I
was like one day that's gonna pay
dividends y'all and it finally turned
into a signing bonus talking with the
great Marcellus Wiley former NFL All-Pro
defensive man he's the host of more to
it on The Dan Patrick Podcast Network
it's funny because I remember one time I
said something to my mom about how you
know I I liked girls like her like you
know she's five nine and broader
shoulder not as big as your mom but
broader shoulder and five nine I said I
I don't because back then
um Marcellus the models were like Kate
Moss and stuff so like any of the
magazines they were like like way for
thin I was like I'm not into that I like
I said I said look you Mom you're big
but beautiful and my dad looked at me
Marcellus like you're dead you're dead
and my mom said she took a sip of like
her wine she's like well you know Ross
I looked different before I had a 10
pound baby and it was 11 years old
um so let's get into a couple of these
football things the Russell Wilson point
you made is a really good one I thought
it was interesting Marcellus hearing or
seeing I guess Mike Purcell
go after Russell Wilson in the game or
at least go up to him because Dan asked
me about it on Monday and I said to him
I don't know the tone there was it like
encouraging like come on man you can do
this or was it like hey bro get your you
know what together because to me
Marcellus those are two very different
things
yeah they're two different things but
you don't have to know what the tone was
to know that this was insubordination
and this is not supposed to happen when
Russell Wilson your franchise
quarterback is going through his
struggles your team is going through his
struggles the head coach is going
through his struggles so you know that
any conversation that has that type of
look we know what the context is and we
know how we're going to interpret it
it's going to be contentious so now you
have a lineman I don't give a damn who
he is coming up to the Star Quarterback
and trying to check them on the
sidelines you only do that when you're
losing respect for who that guy is like
you let his reputation proceed him he's
a future Hall of Famer he's a champion
you know he's your franchise quarterback
and you let one slide you let another
pass slide you had another quarter slide
you let another game slide and finally
you're at your Wit's End and you're like
dude I don't give a damn who you are but
blah blah blah so that showed me that
this is not only something that Russell
Wilson has to deal with losing respect
on that team but more importantly how
many guys have he lost because you know
when one guy comes up to you he's fueled
by 10 other guys who want to say the
same damn thing
so the one thing I really liked about
the point you made on your podcast more
to it part of The Dan Patrick Podcast
network is how so much of what Russell's
done over the years is the second
reaction stuff which is why I'm not
really buying the new offense thing that
much because what's always made him a
special player is the second reaction
stuff I don't know if he has it anymore
I don't know if he can do it anymore and
if he doesn't have a second reaction
stuff he's got a problem and Denver's
got a major problem yeah if you think
about it Russell Wilson has thrived off
of Plan B in terms of play calling for
so long and now because he's not honed
in on those fundamentals plan a staying
on script staying on schedule it seems
like it's a little too late to try and
fix his issues I don't know what's going
to be to solve but it won't be different
play calling because Russell Wilson his
reflexes are to always let the play
break down not to stay on that first
read second read and then try to bail
out but Russell Wilson likes to bail out
first and that's when he has the most
success so you think about it it's been
really disguised because he's had a
tremendous defense in Seattle the early
years especially and he had the running
game in Seattle so now you're in just a
play action passing safer passes and
also a time for you to take off and get
big dividends now they're just saying
look we know what you like to do Russell
Wilson so we're going to take that off
the board now you have to beat us by
being disciplined now you have to beat
us by that strict play call and Russell
Wilson so far is failing at it
curious to get your take on Jeff
Saturday I know you've talked about him
being a coach with Dan the last couple
weeks but what about what happened
Monday night not calling the time out
and then yesterday Jeff accepting
accountability for it and saying that he
made the mistake what did you think of
that
ah look
um it's two things conflating as one
um I've seen Bill Belichick have
coaching mistakes Miss Q's errors uh I
can remember a fourth and two in
Indianapolis a few years ago like every
coach has this mistake on their resume
the thing is when you don't have that
deeper resume let's not have that
mistake happen too early because now
we're going to say C that's why he's
unqualified see this is why you
shouldn't skip the line well the
greatest coach of all time on down has
had this same clock management issue
before at the end of the game that said
uh this is how you take your lunch this
is how you go through the growing pains
this is the rights of Passage in terms
of making a mistake owning that mistake
and making sure that's something you
never do again and that's how we learn
the game as well how many times did you
come back from a game whether it was a
glowing performance or one that made you
put your head down and then you start
watching film and coach gets that red
dot on you and he says see this right
here see this right here and then next
time you're out there you're only
cognizant of it because it was
highlighted as a miscue so for me and
Jeff Saturday I thought it was a good
hire I'm getting really tired of the
same old rigmarole of okay you're a
assistant coach and then you become a
coordinator and your team is top five as
a coordinator on defense and offense and
then you become a head coach and you're
going to fail because you're going to a
bad team in a bad organization and the
cycle continues so hey shake it up a
little bit and Jeff Saturday is going to
learn the hard way but I still think it
was a good hire
Marcellus if you were running the show
in Green Bay let's I don't care if
you're the head coach the floor maybe
you're the GM gutokunt how much longer
are you rolling with Aaron Rodgers this
year or when are you trying to see what
you got and Jordan love for the rest of
the year ah I mean that's a question
that's too late to ask right now because
you committed three years 150 million to
them but I get the gist of what you're
saying um I don't need to see Jordan
love when I have that type of commitment
to a first ballot Hall of Famer top 10
top five quarterback of all time I'm
riding it to the wheels fall off and we
know that the wheels could fall off this
year mathematically once they're
eliminated from the playoffs the
injuries won't be my concern if I'm the
coach if I'm the general manager if I'm
an organization if he wants to play he
will play because we committed to him
and he's committed to this game Jordan
love I've seen Jordan love I Jordan love
practices every day Jordan love was in
the games last year we know what Jordan
love is and it's not Aaron Rodgers and
probably not a good enough version or
portion of Aaron Rodgers for you to feel
full confidence if he were we would have
seen him earlier they would have changed
the narrative last year and allowed him
more opportunity so to say now I want to
go back to Jordan love because Aaron
Rodgers is hurt and the team is bad
let's just see what we have
that's Fool's Gold this is what happens
to every team that hits adversity every
team that goes through their eels the
most popular player on that team is the
backup quarterback because he holds
everyone's imagination everyone's oh if
we put him in everything can change and
most times that's a failing situation we
already know who Jordan love is this is
not the time to see more
make sure you check him out Marcellus
Wiley on more to it on The Dan Patrick
Podcast Network this week Marcel is
going to tell you why obj should be
wearing that star on the side of his
helmet soon how DeSean Watson got in
this predicament just days before his
return which weirdly we're not really
talking about all that much and how T.O
was lucky he didn't get more than he
paid for at CVS Marcellus really
appreciate the time thank you so much
all right take care ivy keep it going
Ross all right there he is Marcellus
Wiley the guy that made me feel like I
couldn't play in the ivy league that was
wild I remember thinking oh boy I'm in
trouble